so in some breaking news on the war in
Ukraine Russia's defense minister Sergey
shoigu has ordered his troops to
withdraw from the West Bank of the
dinipro river that's near the southern
city of Harrison let's bring in Assad
big he's joining us from Central Ukraine
with more on the story what do we know
about this withdrawal assets
well he took to the airwaves to say that
he had ordered the beginning of the
troops from the west side of that River
to the east side now the regional
Capital person the only Regional Capital
that Russia has taken since the start of
this war is on the west side so
essentially what he has said on air is
to withdraw the troops from the capital
Carson now prior to him speaking the
general in charge of the war has said
that he that it was no longer possible
to protect the settlements in her son
under the current conditions and to
protect the defensive line is better to
withdraw the troops but they also said
that the reason for this withdrawal was
because they have information that the
ukrainians want to Brum they have cut
down
now the context to this is that the
Russians have been saying that they've
been evacuating citizens from Carson
that they've been saying officials have
been saying that this is the most
decisive battle of this war the
officials have been liking it to staling
garage during the second world war where
there were two million casualties the
ukrainians were saying that there are
still 20 to 25 000 Russian troops in
that Regional Capital that they had upon
civilian clothes that they had taken at
positions that they were getting ready
for Street battles but now we're hearing
that the Russians are going to withdraw
now we haven't had word from the
ukrainians yet but throughout this and
the run-up to today and this
announcement we've heard both sides
blaming each other accusing each other
for targeting that Dam causing those
blackouts but also accusing each other
of wanting to blow it up now the
Russians are saying they're withdrawing
because they believe the ukrainians want
to blow it up now if that dam is blown
it will cause a disaster there will be
uh the the region the capital will get
flooded uh President Vladimir zielinski
the Ukrainian president had urged
Western leaders to warn Russia not to
blow it now Ukraine has from the very
beginning said that it is in fact Russia
that wants to blow that down but the
latest news is that this Regional
Capital that Russia was holding on to
that strategic about that strategic for
them that's militarily important to them
is the gateway to the South is it's uh
it's a gateway to Crimea right it opens
up their troops in the east of the
country right so I said how significant
then is this announcement of withdrawal
in the context of the ongoing fighting
on the ground in other parts of the
country
well again what happens is if they
withdraw and yet the ukrainians are yet
to confirm we have to see if the
ukrainians enter that city and what
faces them when they do enter that
Regional Capital it means that Russia
has lost the only position on the west
side of that danipro River their troops
in the East are potentially opened up
the the Left Flank of them is opened up
to Ukrainian uh attacks the uh the Water
Supply to Crimea is also under threat
because because when Russia annexed
Crimea in 2014 Ukraine cut off the water
when the Russians took her son they
reinstated that water supply and it was
one of the reasons Vladimir Putin gave
for The Invasion so it opens up all
these possibilities but it's the
significance is that this will be seen
by the ukrainians as a major victory and
a major defeat for Russian President
Vladimir Putin okay thank you so much as
a big reporting from Ukraine thank you